تحصل عمليه زراعه الكبد الكبد الذي لم يعد
يعمل كما ينبغي ويصاب بما يسمى فشل الكبد
يتم استبداله بكبد سليم متبرع متوفي عاده
لكن عدد الاشخاص الذين ينتظرون عمليه
زراعه كبد يتجاوز بكثير عرضك بعد
المتبرعين المتوفين ويمثل تلقي جزء من
الكبد من متبرع حي بديلا عن انتظار توفر
كبد متبرع متوفي لان الكبد البشري يتجدد
ويعود الى حجمه الطبيعي ويؤدي وظيفته
الطبيعيه بعد فتره وجيزه من الاستئصال
الجراحي لجزء من العضو عمليات الزرع من
متبرع هي لها نتائج جيده لكن العثور على
متبرع حي قد يكون صعبا يخضع المتبرعون
بالكبد الاحياء لتقييم المكثف للتاكد لمده
طابوقهم مع طلق الاعضاء ولتقيم مساحتهم
البدنيه والعقليه وبحسب ما يقلينك غالبا
ما يحدث اشخاص الذين يتلقون كبده المتبرعا
حي بمدلاء بمعدلات نجاه اعلى اعلى المدى
القصير مقارنه بمدينه جدا من متبرع متوفي